you know i'm i've got the pleasure of
introducing our speaker and so our
speaker grew up here in portland she
graduated from Wilson high school and
she just finished her freshman year at
Stanford University where she's studying
mathematical computational sciences
there so she's going back in a few weeks
and it's really been great to have
Jordan here during the past few weeks
doing the past few months you know one
of the group I work with a group you
know that does sort of artificial
intelligence and deep learning for a
diagnosis of eye disease and it's been
really really nice to have Jordan around
she's smart and she works hard and she's
done a lot of neat things to someone so
that that's what she'll be talking about
so if you can help me um welcome Jordan
Schuster okay so as dr. Tang said one
thing that we've been doing down in his
lab but Casey is deep learning for
diagnosing retinopathy of prematurity
and along with retinopathy prematurity
one big impact is image quality so Erin
corner a PhD in our lab recently made a
deep learning based method for looking
at image quality and so what I was doing
was looking at the relationship between
image quality and diagnostic ability so
the first step in looking at this and
looking at what is ROP and our piece
right not the prematurity and
specifically what Plus disease is and
then what the automated systems do and
that being the diagnostic system and
image quality assessment system and then
the relationship between ro PE and the
diagnostic ility and image quality and
then other possible measures of quality
so retinopathy prematurity is the
leading cause of blindness in children
so with more neonatal care available
there's more premature babies born and
at about 16 weeks your retinal vessels
will start to grow and by a full-term
pregnancy
you'll have retinal vessels that grow to
the edge of retina when babies are born
prematurely they have the opportunity to
grow abnormally and cause bleeding or
scar tissue which in severe cases can
pull on the retina and cause a retinal
detachment so it's completely treatable
if you catch it early enough but that's
the trick you have to catch it early
enough when to treat it is when you see
Plus disease so here you can see a few
images pluses use on the left here is
defined by tortuosity and dilation in
two or more quadrants so it's kind of
difficult to see but here you can see
kind of angry looking almost vessels
that are squiggly and a little bit
thicker pre plus disease it's harder to
see you because of the quality on the
screen but it still has tortuous vessels
but a lesser amount and then normal has
very thin not dilated straight vessels
so in kind of the most of your cases it
looks like this which is very easy to
classify as plus disease but where you
have tortuosity and dilation and it's
very easy to see it's in even more than
any two quadrants of the eye but the
majority of the time it's a lot more
ambiguous so here there's some
subjectivity and qualitative parts of
diagnosing class disease rather than
quantitative so here we have two images
that are both pre plus but one is on the
lower end closer to normal and one is on
the higher end closer to plus so in this
particular case they were taken from a
set of a hundred images which a
traitor's individually graded each image
normal pre plus and plus with both of
these they were it was not a complete
consensus so in both of these in both of
these on the right here them closer to
normal one about half the people said it
was normal and half the people said it
was pretty plus and then I'll write
about half people said it was plus and
half the people so it was pre plus so in
these cases the right answer is pre plus
but the diagnosis may be variable even
among the best experts
so dr. Chang did a study at one point
looking at inter rater agreement more
more specifically and this was on the
same or three four images 22 experts and
only four images out of the 30 for all
22 experts agreed on the same three
class classifications so there were four
images that were looked at like these
where every single expert said the same
thing which is very low and so it just
shows that diagnosing Autopia can be
very imperfect and so this is the
motivation for computer-based analysis
to give a very objective only looking at
what's there and not any gut feeling
where this looks worse this looks less
with husband so James Brown previously
at mass generated a deep learning system
for this and to explain a little bit
what deep learning is they used a
convolutional neural net which as the
simplest takes in an image and outputs
probabilities so it takes an image and
each layer shown here no one that's made
up of layers does a different different
algorithm or process on the image to the
point where it gets to the end and at
that point you can make a decision based
on probabilities so with machine
learning you have to have training and
testing so in a large dataset of around
5,000 images the system was trained and
on labeled data and one thing that's
really hard about machine learning and
any medical field is labeling data
accurately so in this case the best you
can possibly do is to get a group of
experts to come together and label data
and so one problem is that we kind of
showed previously that experts don't
always agree and so that is the case
when making an RC air reference standard
and so it's very difficult and
time-consuming to come and have the best
experts look at images
five thousand images and say this is
what I think it is and then if there's
disagreements coming through and making
a consensus on what we think it is and
so that's a very large component on how
a machine learning system learns is
going through the process and guessing
on what an image is and then picking a
label for it and adjusting what it
thinks it is so in our case we start
with a fundus image which is here and
then there is two steps in making a
compilation over on it the first of
which learns and has to make a
segmentation and so this is what we
refer to as a segmentation it pulls out
the vessels and so one thing that this
does is it takes away the coloration of
the image and when you're looking at
plus disease you're very specifically
looking at the vasculature
so is it dilated is it tortuous and by
pulling out the vessels we can be sure
that it's only looking at what we think
it's looking at and so from this it
takes a classification type machine
learning algorithm which is like other
end of the convolutional neural net and
outputs three probabilities the three
probabilities correspond to the
probability of the image being a normal
image it being a pre post image and
applause image so here you can see this
image has dilated and tortuous vessels
and that carries into the segmentation
which you can see a little bit clearer
and then the probability of normal and
creep was almost zero and the
probability of plus is almost one and so
one thing you can note with when it
outputs these probabilities they always
add to one and so in some cases it can
be really sure like this image and then
in some cases it can be really unsure or
that mean may be a case where two of the
probabilities were close to half or in
very very unlikely cases they're almost
evenly split so Aaron Corners algorithm
which was an automated assessment of
image quality was made basically so if
you're looking as an expert at a retinal
image and it looks like the one here
where you can barely see anything how
are you supposed to make a diagnosis off
of it and that carries into how's the
computer supposed to make a diagnosis
off of it if we can't see anything
and so I originally yeah idea was to see
is the computer doing better off of
better quality images so we can't expect
it really to do to do well on poor
quality images so in the original test I
was working on just now that James Brown
me he actually took out most of the
nautical ecology images like this but in
this case we want to look at all
qualities of images and so we get an
image and a probability just like the
last one
since its convolutional neuron that you
take an image and you get a probability
and close to zero is poor quality and
close to one is high quality so you can
see going across the side here this very
poor quality gets almost zero the medium
quality where you can see some bags
vasculature on the outside gets about
50% and then the very good image
gets almost 1 and so looking at the
relationship between diagnostic
abilities and image quality first we
want to make a test set and what was
important for us was that none of the
previous algorithms had trained on the
data set that we had use so for those
who are not as familiar with machine
learning if you see an algorithm a image
that has trained on it will be almost it
will have memorizes essentially so you
would get artificially heightened
performance if you were to give it
yeah that's trained on so what we did
was taking a data set of 6000 and
removing all the images that were
trained on and so we were left with two
and then deciding what measures to
calculate the performance on so we used
a SC being area under the curve ROC
curve sensitivity specificity NPV and
PPV one thing that's really important
about medical uses of machine learning
in particular is to use more holistic
measures of what good performance is
because if you have a disease problem
very low and your machine learning
algorithm maybe does a 95% accuracy and
you have maybe three percent prevalence
then it could have missed all the
pertinent images so we want to make sure
that it's missing the images or it's
getting right the images that we wanted
here right and it's missing
images that maybe we don't know why but
it's getting the correct ones right and
wrong and then so the graphs here are
not completely intuitive but the x-axis
is image quality cutoff which is kind of
hard to see but looking at different
image quality cut-offs and at each one
taking out all of the data that is below
the cutoff so at zero on the end here
you are using all the data because all
of the image quality values and these
being the probabilities outputted from
the previous image quality CNN all the
quality values that were above a certain
point and then running the numbers on
them so on the end here that's the
entire data set because everything is
what's your own and then when it cuts
closer to one you have only the very
best quality images you're running these
diagnoses on one other thing to note is
that there's two graphs here so the
output probabilities from the diagnostic
CNN is three we have three probabilities
and for most of these measures it only
requires two or you can only really give
it two so we broke it down into normal
and three plus and plus together and so
that would be more of like a screening
situation and then a plus and vs. pretty
closely normal and so kind of what we
expected to see was a curve more like
this where it increases as quality
increases but we can see it's relatively
flat and if anything it almost curves
down as quality increases which doesn't
totally make sense sense for us when we
see a better quality images it's easier
to make a diagnosis also so it may not
be the case for computers in this case
in particular but two things we were
thinking from this one is does image
quality matter really is there a
difference or does the image quality
algorithm work so after going through
and looking at the image quality
algorithm we kind of concluded that yeah
that's a high quality image that it said
was a high quality image that's low
maybe it's working fine and so we were
kind of left with the idea that quality
does not isn't positively correlated
with increased performance so it's more
it does the same across any kind
qualities and then after seeing this
since we'd hoped for and more like
increasing type curve we were looking at
other different possible types of
quality and so the first of which being
the proportions of it images segmented
so these are two examples of
segmentations we saw when we were
looking at the way of CNN works it makes
an image and then a segmentation and
then three probabilities based off of it
so one thing that's different than this
then regular image quality like looking
at the haziness of the image is that the
computer is seeing the segmented image
so the quality of what the computer
seeing is more based on the segmented
image than the image quality of the
haziness because the computer is
actually much better at looking at this
like picking out vessels and segmenting
them than people are so here we think
that a higher quality image would have
more segmentation so we can see at the
top here we have a pretty high quality
image and we see a lot of vasculature
and then the bottom we have a very low
quality image so what happened here is
in very very low quality image the CNN
outputs a grayscale image so a matrix of
intensity values and when the grayscale
image it's almost completely black the
intensity values are very low and so the
CNN that classifies and puts out the
probabilities looks at 8 binarized image
meaning it's no longer grayscale it's
all ones and zeros so in between when
the in between when it's segments and
when the probabilities are being made it
is binarized and so when it's almost
black in the grayscale image the there
are usually very small very small pixels
that have really small intensity values
so here what happened was when its
threshold encoder and then binarize
above the threshold since the values are
very low the threshold is very low then
it happens to segment things that we
don't really want and so in this case
that's a way that this wouldn't
necessarily work because it's a kind
thing things that we don't really want
to see but in the majority of cases
with the higher quality image you see
more segmented and so this is a graph in
the middle is image quality scores
versus the proportion of the image
segmented so they're relatively loosely
correlated positively and so any
background noise is picked up which is
kind of a challenge here and it
automatically counts it as relevant
vasculature and then this is keeping
track of the quality of the segmentation
rather than an image so it's not
necessarily supposed to be exactly like
the quality mentioned that we have
before so the same graphs were run on
these ones and unfortunately they're
definitely worth looking so it's not
necessarily clear to us why they may
decrease so much as the proportion of
the image segmented goes up but you can
see it's kind of steady and then drops
off so the proportion image segmented
just has too many things different than
what we're really looking for and so
it's not necessarily a good quality
measure the second one was the top five
contiguous components this being like if
you were to look at the top image a lot
of the vessels are connected and so
they're very long and take up more of
the image so it would take the top 5
largest pixels like groups of pixels the
group's being parts that are connected
so that would eliminate the fact that
it's picking up on all of the spinous of
this image it might only pick up on the
three largest or five largest spots and
so in the high quality images this ends
up being almost exactly the same as the
number of pixels segmented and doesn't
really change anything as a quality
measure compared to the last one and in
some cases that are very low quality
images instead of like long scale ions
like we would hope you get more like
blobs in the middle which unfortunately
count as many pixels maybe as a long
skinny line which you can't control as
much and then this is the graphs kind of
for those and they look almost identical
to the total number of pixels segmented
because they're very similar but you can
see it decreases as quality decreases
or as a number of pixels increase which
is not really clear we saw in the
original that in some cases it just on
total number of images there were more
higher quality images miss than lower
quality images which were in the process
of looking at why that happens now but
in this case it decreases our like by a
much larger amount so in general what we
came up with was at the state that tprop
is now which is the diagnostic system is
it's not clear that there is a
correlation between image quality and
diagnostic ability so as the state it is
right now that has the same performance
on lower quality images and higher
quality images and and that may change
in future ones where we would maybe
something changes with the algorithm
itself and now diagnosis more higher
quality images but wait the way it is
now it's unclear on what there's really
a correlation between them and then in a
lot of machine learning applications
what's really published and publicized
is where it gets things right it had a
98% accuracy but in our case especially
when the stakes are high
you need to diagnose bus disease - for a
child to get treatment we need to look
at where images fail so what we're doing
now is going through we think that you
can classify errors from this diagnostic
system into discreet bins and then maybe
that would tell us something about how
to change it in the future for example
if we go through and it looks like all
the cases it missed we're borderline
cases that may argue for a more
continuous scale since as we saw earlier
things may not perfectly fit into three
bins they may be closer to normal then
pre plus or closer to plus and pre plus
and it's hard to put it in between or
the segmentation errors and maybe change
something about the way that the
algorithm segments or its quality issues
in which case you set a cut-off value so
that's mainly now misty and I are
working towards that and going through
all of the images that it missed
looking at Wyatt got it wrong could
there be underlying reason that a lot of
them are getting it wrong and so uh I
just want to thank dr. Chang and Pete
Campbell who was not here and Susan and
Misty and Aaron were all big people who
were always in KC a new lab and Andy
might send national library medicine but
mainly one thing I did not expect from
informatics I expected she mostly had a
computer but the group down there makes
a very good point of bringing people
together for meetings and conferences
with other people in the country and
staying up to date on what everyone else
is doing and being very supportive and
checking up and helping you get things
that you need which I was thank you for
that I just had a quick question about
the you said that the quality you know
wasn't correlated with the performance
but I wondered whether that was the
correlations were kind of equally true
whether the performance meant agreeing
that something was negative versus
agreeing that something was positive you
know was there any difference in how it
performed with the images that it was
going to find to be negative versus how
it performed with the images that were
positive so well one issue that we had
with our data set of because the
prevalence of disease is lower in our
data set of like 1100 we only had like
39 plus images and so it didn't seem
like there was a lot a big connection
between the positive cases getting wrong
in the negative cases getting wrong one
thing that was interesting that we tried
to go about fixing but couldn't figure
out a way to do because the data set was
so small is that rebalancing the
distribution of the quality of images so
kind of unfortunately for us a big
majority of the
plus the seized images I think 11 out of
39 were poor quality and what the what
the quality assessment measure called
poor quality and so we tried to go about
finding other images but of course the
datasets are what you have and you can't
to prevent data leakage being trained on
an image before we didn't what we had so
it didn't look like there was a
difference in positive versus negative
cases but of course we had a very small
amount
[Applause]
okay while they're switching out I'll
introduce the next speaker
so I'm David Orr and I'm pleased to
introduce nathie pi who is a senior at
Oregon State studying Public Health and
Human Development and Family sciences
and she really did a wonderful job I
give our group care management plus
studies basically how data information
and knowledge can impact the health and
well-being of vulnerable populations and
you'll see she took on a really
important aspect of that with this study
by looking at psychosocial factors on
patients with multi mobility
I turned off
sneak peek
all right my monitor keeps turning off
sorry
Monique I'm not sure what happened
thank you all right can you hear me yes
cool all right
thank you for the introduction doctor
door and thank you everyone for being
here today are tuning in to the live
stream I know a couple people I know are
I had the privilege of being the care
management plus enter in this summer and
working on several grants with the care
management plus team and I'm going to be
presenting on one of those grants which
centered around analyzing the effects of
psychosocial factors on patients with
multi morbidity so quickly about care
management plus the CMP team basically
has a mission to better understand how
data information and knowledge can be
used and leveraged to shape and
transform health outcomes for vulnerable
populations so coming in from a public
health major with a strong foundation of
public health knowledge but no
experience in informatics or what that
really meant I learned a lot this summer
in the last ten weeks from the CMP team
about how public health and informatics
come together to shape health outcomes
for individuals and populations so I
know we have an audience today with
various backgrounds in public health and
informatics so before I jump into the
research I just want to start by
painting a quick picture of the
healthcare challenges that are driving
the needs for research like this in the
first place so starting with models of
healthcare which are basically ways of
conceptualizing health or thinking about
health achieving health so our current
US healthcare system is largely based on
what is known as the biomedical model of
health in this model the primary focus
is on the biological and the physical
aspects of disease and illness and some
of the primary aims for patient care are
to diagnose treat and cure so that
patients are turned to a pre illness
State so there are a lot of strengths
with this model and it's brought a lot
of advancements and life expectancy and
the quality of life and patient care
that we can provide but one of the
significant gaps in this model is that
the emphasis on biological determinants
means that social and behavioral
determinants of health are generally
excluded or overlooked in care so now
there's a growing body of understanding
on social and environmental factors that
shape our health and need to be
addressed to achieve holistic health and
well-being and these are known as the
social determinants of health so as you
can see in this table there are a lot of
examples of social determinants of
health everything from education to food
security to the quality of our health
care system all of which interact to
shape the health outcomes highlighted
there in the orange bar so the last
model I'm going to discuss today is the
bio biopsychosocial model of disease and
illness so the BPS model looks at
biological psychological and social
needs of patients and how they all
interact to shape disease and health
outcomes and the BPS grant was the
foundation of the grant that are not the
BPS grant the BPS model was the
foundation of the grant that i got to
assist with this summer so despite
growing a growing body of knowledge on
social determinants of health and the
impact that they have on our health and
well-being
there are still significant gaps in
integrating this knowledge into clinical
care and into workflows in a significant
way that this manifests is an EHR
documentation so you've all probably
heard of vital signs which are indica
measurements that are indicative of
various aspects of our health so we have
biological vital signs things like blood
pressure height weight BMI all of which
typically address our biological and
physical needs these biological vital
vital signs vital signs are entered into
structured data fields in EHRs like epic
which makes it easier to evaluate and
act on them then we have psychosocial
vital signs which are factors like
financial resource strain housing
loneliness stress all of which are
indicative of psychological and social
needs of patients currently what we're
seeing is that these psychosocial vital
signs are
generally entered into unstructured data
fields like notes which makes it a lot
harder to evaluate and act on them
consistently so now what we're seeing is
that we have a lot of unstructured notes
but that this is a largely untapped
resource of
a lot of rich information that could
have a lot of implications for patient
health specifically for psychosocial
factors there's a lot we still don't
know about how psychosocial factors
interact with biomedical determinants of
health how they how and if they
exacerbate disease and if they put in
certain populations at higher risk of
adverse health outcomes so that leads me
to an overarching question of this
research and that is can patients with
psychosocial factors be identified
despite this unstructured documentation
and the answer is yes past work by
Greenwald and team used keywords and
national natural language processing
methods to mine several thousand patient
notes for physical cognitive and
psychosocial constructs the following
year a study by dr. Bayesian and team
used various methodologies to mine
several million patient notes for
homelessness and adverse childhood
experiences so this dr. beige John's
work was the foundation of the grant
that I got to work on this summer our
grant looked at four psychosocial
concepts one of them was homelessness
which was replicated from the previous
grant and the other three concepts we
looked at were chronic stress social
isolation and financial insecurity all
of which are known to be associated with
adverse health outcomes of patients so
the specific target population that we
looked at in this study was adults ages
65 and older experiencing multi
morbidity which is the presence of two
or more co-occurring chronic conditions
so currently in this is based on recent
data about a fourth of the American
population is experiencing multi morbid
and over 75% of people ages 65 and over
are experiencing multi morbidity and
despite advancements in health care in
medicine this rate is increasing I don't
know why that's right over the words
what we also know is that patients who
are experiencing multi morbidity are
more vulnerable to a variety of adverse
health outcomes so for example patients
with five experiencing five or more
chronic conditions are found to
experience five times the rate of risk
of functional loss and 90 times the risk
of hospitalizations and also represent a
district or disproportionately high
percentage of healthcare costs so this
is what shaped the inclusion criteria
for our study to be included in the
analyses patients had to be 65 years or
older by the year of analysis had to be
experiencing multi morbidity and the
third inclusion criteria was that they
had to have a minimum of one identified
Cee'd word so seed words are basically
single or multi word expressions that
are determined to be associated with the
concepts of interest now why is this
important well each of these social
determinants is very complex and there's
a lot of indicators that a patient could
be experiencing them for example if a
patient is found to be residing in the
shelter could be an indicator that
they're experiencing homelessness if a
patient is repeatedly referred to a
stress management class could be an
indicator that they're experiencing
chronic stress
so basically collectively these seed
words these are the ones we determined
for our research the seed words create a
phenotypic profile for each of the
social determinants that allow us to
broaden the scope of the search and
identify even more patients who might be
experiencing these psychosocial
constructs so before we get to the point
of identifying seeds in our methodology
this research started with a data set of
3.2 8 million patients from 120
different sites this data
was then narrowed down to just 2016 and
2017 data containing information on
eighty thousand seven hundred and forty
eight patients who met the inclusion
criteria following this process we
identified notes of patients using seeds
who were found to be experiencing those
psychosocial constructs any seeds that
were had identified notes incorrectly or
erroneously were either reformulated or
removed from the analyses using negation
filtering following this process based
on our seed profile and how well all of
the patient notes matched that seed
profile patients were assigned a
relevance score with higher relevant
scores indicating better matches to
those seeds and probably higher
prevalence of that concept in their
notes so this fourth stage is where I
actually joined the CMP team this summer
the manual annotation process and the
point of this phase was basically to
validate the retrieved list of patients
and to make sure that the patients that
had been retrieved by the software were
actually experiencing the psychosocial
constructs that they said they were and
so for this process of colleague and I
went through 400 patient notes in total
and this and this process basically
involved reviewing patient notes and
assigning patients a score on a zero to
five scale based on how well patient
notes matched and how well sorry I lost
my train of thought based on how well
the psychosocial construct was present
in their notes so zero a score of zero
indicated that the psychosocial
construct was definitely not present
score of five indicated that it was
definitely present and so if a patient
had a score of three four or five that
was deemed a true positive for our
analyses so these are the results from
that manual annotation of four hundred
patients which revealed pretty
moderately to highly significant
precision and precision ranges and
average scores for patients with
precision ranges
going from 0.78 to 0.93 and average
scores ranging from 3.9 three to four
point six five which indicated that most
of the patients that had been extracted
were indeed true positives for the
psychosocial construct
so after this phase the grant was
submitted pretty shortly after this face
so in the last few weeks of my
internship I got to spend my time
learning about R and statistics
reteaching my self statistics and
exploring the data to see if it could
answer some of the questions that we had
so my main questions with this data were
to look at the effect of psychosocial
factors like the four I mentioned
earlier and to see if they had an effect
on exacerbating or increasing the
frequency of health outcomes for
patients with multi morbidity so the
specific health outcomes that we looked
at for this data were unplanned health
care utilization and disease
exacerbation to look at the impact on
these outcomes over time we used 2016
the 2016 and 2017 dataset of 80,000
patients and then compared it to outcome
data from 2018 so for this outcome data
we used 2018 information on hospital and
emergency department visits by that data
set of patients and for disease
exacerbation used icd-10 diagnostic
codes to assess the presence of 19
standardized mental and somatic health
conditions and patient records so just a
quick look at what that data actually
showed so of our total population of
eighty thousand seven hundred and
forty-eight patients in that data set
about 55 percent were female forty-five
percent were male with an average age of
about 70 1.98 we'll just say seventy two
years of the four psychosocial factor is
the one that seemed to have the highest
prevalence was chronic stress with about
thirteen percent of the eighty thousand
patients identif
as having a true positive for chronic
stress on the other hand social
isolation seemed to have the least
prevalence of the four here with just
0.4 eight percent but still 362 patients
identified as having social isolation
and lastly about 4,000 patients were
identified as having one or more
hospitalization in the year 2018 and
indicating a rate of about 50 per 100
950 per 1,000 patient years so the
predictive analysis method that I used
in our this summer was primarily binary
logistic regression which is a method
that basically looks at the relationship
between a dependent binary variable and
a set of independent variables basically
what the regression does it is it
predicts the probability that a certain
binary outcome will occur based on a set
of predictor factors so my first
question in this analysis was to see if
there was a relationship between the
presence or absence of a psychosocial
factor and the probability of a
hospitalization either yes they were
hospitalized or no they did not have one
or more hospitalization so the results
on this oops yep
the results on this showed that odds
ratios were greater than two for all for
psychosocial factors and had
statistically significant p-values and
this indicated that yes indeed for all
for psychosocial factors if a patient
had one of those factors present in
their notes they were at an increased
likelihood of hospitalization if they
were patients with multi morbidity and
my second question was similar and
looked at the patient relevant scores
that were determined based on how well
patients matched with the Cee'd word
profiles we'd created and then compared
that to the probability of
hospitalization so I was able to
generate these graphs based on that
regression and it looks like for chronic
stress homelessness and financial
insecurity an increase in relevance does
indicate an increase in the probability
of hospital admission now the exception
to this in this example was social
isolation which did not appear to be
statistically significant in this model
one reason for this could just be
because of the volume of the data that
we had on social isolation we had
significantly less than on the other
psychosocial factors which could have
affected affected the probability of
social isolation and hospitalization but
regardless I think all four of these
graphs still show us a really
interesting relationship between these
two factors now my third research
question was to look at the relationship
between the disease diagnosis that we
had extracted and the presence in the
absence of a psychosocial concept so to
see if having a certain disease
diagnosis increased the likelihood of
having a psychosocial factor as well so
to start with this I started by running
a multivariate analysis which we're all
nineteen of the diagnosis we were
looking at were compared to each
psychosocial factor in dividual II and
this is where I ran into a fun challenge
with logistic regression so in this
example with chronic stress there are
several diseases that are statistically
significant predictors of chronic stress
one of the disease's conditions that is
not is substance II substance use so to
explore this a little bit more I ran a
univariate analysis which just compared
substance use to chronic stress and in
this example you can see that substance
use is now a highly significant
predictor so when I first saw this I was
really confused thought I had just
messed everything up but turns out the
challenge has a name and it is
multicollinearity so that is basically a
phenomenon in which two or more
independent variables are highly
linearly
elated and so this is where I learned if
you have a lot of variables and they are
hot especially when they're highly
correlated it increases the chances that
true associations are diluted and makes
it a lot harder to separate the
individual effects of those variables so
one way to address this is by creating
correlation matrices which allow us to
see the correlations between certain
sets of diagnoses so as you can see
hopefully there's a lot of blue in this
correlation matrix indicating that there
are a lot of positive relationships
between certain sets of diagnoses and
basically what this indicates is that
when one diagnosed increases the other
diagnosis is also very likely to
increase and so because of these many
correlations happening between these 19
diagnoses it increases the likelihood
that the individual strength of
predictors is a little different in that
complex model but I think my the biggest
takeaway from that is so this is the
results from the multivariate analysis
you can see that there are a lot of
statistically significant diagnoses for
each of our psychosocial factors but I
think the takeaway is just that when
doing predictive models these models are
fine but it's also important to be aware
of potential correlations in the data
and to see what effect that they might
have on the predictive model so these
are all very initial analyses based on
just a couple weeks of our and
statistics experience but if I had 10
more weeks and more time there are a lot
of huge directions to take this research
in a couple of these future directions
are to identify specific damaging
combinations of psychosocial factors and
chronic conditions to see what health
adverse health outcomes they might cause
and to see what populations they put at
higher risk and why but ultimately the
impact of this research is that it
enhances our ability to identify
vulnerable populations of
vulnerable populations of patients and
to tailor specific interventions to
those populations to prevent poor health
outcomes like disease exacerbation or
hospitalization before they occur so as
I said at the beginning I came in with a
lot of experience in public health and
very little experience in informatics
but and walking away with a broadened
sense of understanding on informatics
techniques and how they apply to the
real world
as well as the implications for research
like this and while I have a better
sense of appreciation for informatics
and data analysis I also learned a lot
about the messiness of data and how hard
it is sometimes to get it to do what you
want so in the process of working
through our I think I learned that the
process a lot of times in data analysis
is more important than the outcome and
that what we do in the process of
cleaning manipulating analyzing our data
shapes the reliability and the quality
of our outcomes and last I learned a lot
about navigating and utilizing resources
available to me whether that was the
people at CMP or the countless our
community forums out there so now I'd
just like to close by saying thank you
to my mentor Dave door and my manager
Christy Fizz Amenti and my colleague
sumit Singh for all of their support and
guidance through my work on this project
and of course to my wonderful care
management plus team for being the most
fun and empowering group of people I
could have worked with this summer and
then of course I'd like to thank the
department demise and NLP training grant
for making this internship possible for
all of us
[Applause]
talk so if you were gonna collect some
more data and you were specifically
gonna follow up on your substance use
findings looking at your correlation
matrix which of all those multi
morbidities would you focus on oh I wish
I was my laptop of finding the
correlations yeah well I had a slide on
the specific highly significant
correlations and the coefficients I
think a really interesting one that we
found was so one of our diseases of
interest was severe mental and illness
and that seemed to have a lot of
correlations for good reason with
conditions like schizophrenia and
dementia so I think I would want to
explore those first those seem to have
the highest correlation coefficient and
the correlation matrix and so I think
exploring that data would be interesting
and to see the predictive value I think
also when I was just exploring data I
found a lot of information on
homelessness and substance use and I
know from other research that's also a
very highly significant relationship
there so I think that's what I would
like to explore a little bit more also
don't I still have this one
which is yes so hello everyone thank you
for coming to my presentation originally
I planned this to be a 30 minute
presentation but looks I have it like I
have less than 10 minutes now so I'll
try to get us all out of here by 12:30
but yes I'm going to be presenting on
how to integrate the natural language
processing into our reactant curation
pipeline so what is reactive now
reactive is an open source and open
access pathway knowledge base what that
means is that in the past years we there
have been an increasing amount of
biological data being sent out by
research being published and it's very
hard to keep this all together and so
what we reactive does is we try to get
all this information for pathways such
as metabolism signal transduction gene
regulation and other biological
processes and package it together and
make it easily displayable and easier to
analyze for lots of different
researchers each of the pathways that we
are using is traced to primary
literature and we extensively
cross-reference all of the
bioinformatics databases with primary
research and other professionals in the
field and we have tools also for
browsing and visualizing the pathway
data and analyzing the user data and fun
fact when dr. Wu was starting out on
this project I was entering kindergarten
and I'm presenting that so why are we
using reactants so there are other
pathway databases such as cake and wiki
pathways and one of the advantages that
reactant has over these pathways is that
it's open source cake currently it used
to be open source but now you need a
license to download it and as
researchers we all like free things we
have wiki pathways which is open source
but it incorporates a wiki style editing
so it's not as reliable you could get
some mistakes here and there we have a
very comprehensive overview of all the
information that goes into react oh so
you can be sure that our data is very
accurate so these are some of the
advantages that reactive
over some other pathway databases that
are out there and here are some
statistics for reactant usage you see
that on average for 2019 per month we
have eight point zero four million
monthly web requests and 75,000 average
monthly users and some peak numbers as
well you can see nine point seven four
million average web requests requests in
March and eighty seven thousand unique
users in April 2009 teen so you can see
that reactant is highly useful to the
biological community by how much use it
gets so where does all of this data come
from well we have authors and we have
curators that are used to write the
modules and pathways so we have a
specific data model set up and our
curators go into it and actually write
down the specific pathways and format
the informations that I can use by our
program authors use our software tool to
describe their pathways all molecules
must be identified and backed up by the
primary literature reactant internal
curators work with authors to ensure the
consistency and completeness and is
checked by multiple levels of peer
review as you can see on the right side
of your screen we have kind of like the
pipeline of how this process goes down
so the editor-in-chief recruits experts
and inside assigns curators they work
together on a module that module gets
okayed then it goes under a first step
of review
maybe revisions might be needed then it
goes to an external review and then that
might be sent back for more review so we
have a very big rigorous process of
reviewing data before it comes into
reactor now what are some of the
problems that come with this well this
is very slow process we have to have
curators go in and putting information
characters that are experts in their
field right now we have around 10
curators working on this globally and
every month or so every quarter we push
out a new version of pathway which of
reactant which has more information but
it's a very slow process and so part of
my work for this summer was trying to
use this tool called reach to make the
process more efficient now what is reach
reach stands for reading and assembling
contextual and holistic mechanisms
from text is a it is developed by the
University of Arizona clue lab and it's
a natural language processing tool which
essentially you can take a research
paper send it in and it will output all
the different pathways all the different
reactions that it finds within the paper
as well as contextual information and
the participants for the pathway so it's
a very useful program for us because
this is perfect this is what our
curators need to be able to add more
information to react them and so some of
my project goals for this summer were to
develop a user interface where curators
could easily access these reach mined
entities and use that to incorporate
into react dome and then the second part
reach has its own data model which it
outputs the information into it outputs
it into an XML file but we have a
specific model for reactants so we want
to somehow be able to take those results
that reach outputs and turn it into our
reactive reaction based data model and
I'm gonna be focusing on this first
option so right now we're not actually
using the reach program itself we're
using a server API that is developed by
Chris Sanders lab in the dana-farber
Cancer Institute in Harvard and what
they've done for us if they've is
they've mined through more than four
hundred thousand papers and sent it
through beech and got the output data
from it and they've developed an API for
us to use now an API if you don't know
it's just a it's a interface where you
can send in information and then get
some information back so see if you can
see here we're sending information to
get the PubMed Commons ID all these
different qualifiers and they're from
the output we can get contact
information we can get what journal the
papers come from so we're using this API
for our project we're not using reach
specifically so here's the information
flow diagram for how this is all going
to be done first we're going to call a
server using the
specific queries that we want to get the
specific information that we want to get
it's gonna run into the the my code
which is going to display it to the
curator we display it to curator and the
curator will have an option to either
accept or reject this to add this to
react tome so hopefully that's the final
place that we wanted to get to it's not
at that point yet but we're still
working towards that so starting with
this internship first I had to study all
the existing code and this entire
program is written completely in Java so
there is a lot to go through this is all
the packages in Java things are
organized into packages and into classes
so we have all the packages just for the
curator tool this is not even for
reactive on its own and all the
different files in a single path package
as you can see here so there's a lot of
information that I had to go through
over this summer it is a bit
overwhelming when I first stepped into
it but that was part of just getting
used to the workflow next we have to
decide on entry point as you can see
here this is what our curator tool looks
like right now this is a specific view
called the entity level view where we
see biological we see proteins we see
ATP and ATP we see where things are
going on inside the cell and where we're
going to be able to use this is say if
you right-click on a protein right here
are b1 CC 1 there will drop down an
option that is search reach and from
there we a table will be pulled up since
the information will be sent into the
reach API and then we'll pull all this
information out and then display it in
this table as you can see here so you
can see there's the protein name the
protein ID the specific PubMed Commons
paper that is linked to otherwise known
as seen here is the PMC ID and then a
brief text which shows a little bit of
context information on that specific
reaction and actually we also have
filtering options so you can filter
based on journal you can filter based on
year and each one of these options here
in this table is actually linked
directly to the PubMed Commons paper
that it comes from so you can double
click on each of these results and it
would bring you straight to the web page
I was going to do a demonstration but
unfortunately that didn't work out so
you have to look at this instead this is
the final product of what I've been
working on for this summer and so we
have some future steps which is to turn
this information that we got here out of
reach and turn it into the the data
model that reactive uses and currently
we're studying in order to do that we're
spending some programs right now reach
we have some programs that outputs reach
format and turns it to bio packs which
is similar to our reaction based data
model it's not exactly the same so we're
standing those programs to see how we
can implement it into our program and
then otherwise optimize the program for
other entity types right now we just
have proteins but we should try to look
for other molecules other different gene
products and lastly I would like to just
thank dr. Wu and his lab for being so
gracious and letting me work on this for
this summer I would like to thank the D
mice Department and the pathway commons
team which is the larger team that works
on reactive as well as other projects
and also the National Library of
Medicine grant for allowing me on here
thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions
thank you